so my name is PAX haymeyer I'm the
director of academic programs at
Stanford online the Stanford center for
professional development I've been at
Stanford for let's hear about uh four
and a half years now so and I've been
mostly in the credit bearing or academic
programs but I've also worked very
closely with Petra on the artificial
intelligence professional programs as
well as the other computer science
professional programs Patrick do you
want to introduce yourself yeah sure
hello welcome everyone my name is Petra
parikova I am the associate director for
our artificial intelligence uh and
computer science programs and courses
more on the professional uh end of the
portfolio we will tell you a little bit
more about the distinction uh in a
little bit thank you for joining us
great go for it Petra sorry so before we
program an AI professional program I
want you to give us like a quick
overview of what else is there so so you
you all know that this is not all like
what we offer at a CPD so we have the AI
graduate program that is more on the
academic part uh that Pax will tell you
more about and then the professional
program I will tell you more about
but then we also have a bunch of other
programs and courses that uh might be a
little bit like less technically heavy
than our AI graduate and professional
programs so if you are new to machine
learning we also have machine learning
specialization on Coursera that is
developed also for people who are just
starting who would like to get the
overview so you know if that course is
more in line if you're when you're with
your interest that might be uh something
you might want to take a look at we also
have some courses that are more focused
for our like managerial audiences
building an AI enabled organization that
is part of our digital transformation
portfolio but we won't be talking about
this we will be focusing on the graduate
program and professional program
specifically that are a little bit more
let's say technically technically heavy
as you will see they have some
prerequisites uh you will see that
obviously those programs cost some money
because we are also providing a bunch of
support and we will tell you all about
the value there is but if you don't have
the the means that to pay for that or if
you're just interested in taking a look
what Stanford has to offer we also have
a lot of free content available out
there so there are a lot of graduate
course lecture videos are available on
YouTube so I would encourage you to just
go and like type in natural language
processing Stanford and something will
pop out it will likely be Chris Manning
with his lectures uh in cs24n and we
have also webinars that we are trying to
run uh you know like like this one but a
little bit less focus on the programs
but more on the content
so I'll give you a general overview of
the two programs and the key differences
and then I will go into more detail on
the AI graduate program and then Petra
will go into more detail on the AI
professional program again I see people
are already asking great questions to
ask those questions we'll answer some of
them here during the webinar some of
them can will be answered uh directly
through the Q a
so the first program is the AI graduate
program and these are the these are the
actual classes that are happening on
Stanford's campus and we schedule them
in one of uh the rooms that Stanford
center for professional development
operates we record the lectures and we
make those available to remote Learners
so the entire class you are taking the
same class as the on-campus students are
taking the only difference is is rather
than sitting in the back of the
auditorium you are watching the lectures
online at your convenience but you are
responsible for all the same assignments
you're responsible for all the same work
as all the on-campus students are
the time commitment for these courses
tends to be about 15 to 20 hours per
week you will have you follow the
Stanford's quarter system which is 10
weeks of instruction in about a week or
two after that for exams
you uh you earn Stanford Credit and you
can transfer up to 18 of those units uh
towards a degree if you take three to
four of these classes you can earn a
graduate certificate but again even if
you take a single class you're earning a
Stanford University transcript and
you're earning academic credit
in terms of the support this is just an
uh this is an on-campus class so you
will watch the lectures at your
convenience again you'll have to be
following the syllabus and keeping up
with the pace of the class but then
there will be some office hours that are
offered online uh there will also be
graduate course assistance there's
usually a student Forum something like
Ed stem somewhere where you can post
questions or slack channels and in
addition to that we have uh on the scpd
side General uh discussion forums for
all students who are taking a graduate
class in any given quarter allowing you
to connect with other students both in
your class but in other classes uh in
other AI classes so again these are the
actual Stanford University graduate
courses you're taking them alongside the
students who are on campus you are
responsible for the same work you're
following the same schedule the only
difference is that you are a remote
student in that
the AI professional program is based
closely on the on the graduate classes
what we do is we take the lecture
recordings that we've already made for
the that we've already made for the
graduate program and we work with the
and we take the syllabus for those class
the syllabi for those classes and we
work with the faculty uh to identify the
core 80 of those classes
and then we we make the other 20
optional and we focus on
and we we then create another version of
that class based on that it's a little
bit less intensive so it's still 10
weeks of instruction but we're looking
at a set of 15 to 20 hours maybe 10 to
15 hours a week you're learning the same
content so it's not less rigorous it's
the same rigor that you're going to find
in the graduate program but we've
identified the core most important
content and that's what we focus on in
this program The Faculty are not
directly involved in the running of each
of these cohorts though again the
materials are entirely based on their
course and they work with us to design
the professional program they will
usually join for a q a session during
each cohort
the credential you get here is a
professional certificate A continuing
education unit so you do not get a
Stanford transcript
um and the the support is through
industry experience course facilitators
your online community of peers and your
networking it is very much a program
that is designed with you as a remote
learner uh in the audience and the final
thing I'll point out is the price so the
graduate programs are about twice as
expensive as the professional programs
uh so usually between four and five
thousand dollars a class whereas the AI
professional programs are between uh
Seventeen hundred and two thousand
dollars a class Petro is there anything
you would add at that high level
overview
maybe I would just say for the AI
professional program so those 80 percent
we are not trying to make the cost
easier or simpler we are not kind of
cutting across like making sure that
everybody can take it not at all we are
trying to like look at pieces that might
be less relevant for industrial or like
you know for professionals who are
working in industry and if we talk about
value and we will talk more about that I
think for the graduate program you're
actually taking the graduate class which
is I think for for many people quite
exciting and you can get it later great
you can get a credit from from Stanford
but for the AI professional program this
might be more of a value for people who
are looking at the same content but they
just know they need a letter grade they
are just like they want to learn they
want to get potential members from their
employer they want to make sure they
stay up to date with the industry and we
will talk more in detail about this yeah
and we'll we'll come back to all these I
see some good questions I want to
address one quick question and circle
back to what Petra said so the first
question is for the AI graduate courses
can you come in person so in general you
should not cut you cannot come in person
for the lectures themselves however if
you are local you can come on campus for
office hours you can usually come on
campus for exams you could come on
campus if you needed to do a poster
session so beyond sort of being in
person in the lecture hall for the most
part if you're local you can come on
campus but a lot of our Learners are not
local so obviously that's not an easy
option that we do have Learners who have
come out from the East Coast for
instance uh to present in their final
projects in person for the AI graduate
program I think I want to reiterate what
Petra said and one way I like to think
about these two programs is the AI
graduate program
when you are a professional student in
that class a remote student that class
really has two audiences they're the
on-campus students who are in front of
the instructor in the auditorium and
then there is you who's a remote learner
and that has two implications one is the
kind of online in person and to be
honest we've provided and created the
infrastructure and support around that
where that difference is not as
significant but the other side of that
of course is that the students in the
classroom are full-time students and the
class has been designed for full-time
students most of you are likely working
professionals or most of our students
who are taking the AI graduate program
have a full-time job in addition to
taking this course and so it's like
they're doing a part-time job on on top
of their full-time job
the fact that there are kind of two
audiences to that course is not really a
bug of the program it's a feature it's
what allows us to do it allows us to
open these courses and to make it fairly
easy and open and accessible is that
scpd
provides the infrastructure and support
for the online students but the faculty
are in there and they're just they're
teaching their same course they're
focused on the best pedagogy and the
best learning methods
um but they're not you know but they
they do have these two audiences the AI
professional program has allowed us to
take that material and to design it with
much more with it with the remote and
professional Learner in mind and so that
means again focusing on the essential
material that means really streamlining
the remote experience of it everyone is
remote so everyone is having that same
experience and allows us to streamline
and focus on those two things
again having the two audiences of is a
feature for many people and something
that is attractive to them because
that's exactly what they want to do they
want the they want the full graduate
experience and for others the content
you know the content sort of is what
their focus is and they want the the
experience that is streamlined and
really focused for their learning needs
so I'm going to uh move to the next
slide and we'll we'll get I want to sort
of build on that idea actually I'll
pause there Petra is there anything you
wanted to add to what I just said
I think you covered it well
okay
um
I'm going to just quickly look
okay great so again building on that for
for the AI graduate program so one thing
do this is a kind of a screenshot of
what you'll see if you go to our website
uh we do have a program plan there's a
lot of information you can find there
including the academic calendar the
program planning document so the thing
they emphasize here I think is is just
the the is the schedule and this is
another difference between the two
programs the AI graduate program is of
course following Stanford's schedule
that means a couple things it means that
we only offer the classes when they're
being offered on campus so a good
example uh Petra mentioned natural
language processing Chris Manning's
class cs224n that's offered every winter
at Stanford so if you want to take it as
the graduate program you must take it in
the winter unless Chris Manning makes
you know it could change because Chris
Manning could decide to offer it at a
different time but it's it's generally
offered every winter that's only when we
can make it available and that 10-week
schedule that winter is going to to
follow Stanford's academic calendar so
the deadlines will all be based on the
Stanford deadlines of when you can drop
of when you can withdraw
and so in terms of planning right you
really need to follow the Stanford
schedule get into on the professional
side we can offer that class more times
than just once a year and we can offer
it different times than the winter and
that allows you more flexibility of when
you can take those classes
uh one other uh one other feature though
of the AI graduate program is it is
because we're we are offering the
on-campus classes we can offer a a large
array of classes a huge variety of
classes so you can see and this is a a
list uh I think maybe a complete list
depending on what if the slide is
getting cut off
of the classes that we offer in the AI
graduate program so uh to sort of
emphasize something I said earlier is
for the AI graduate program you can take
a single course you can also put
together take four of them in order to
earn an accredited certificate and these
are the courses that you can select from
and there are a lot of courses here um
because we can sort of offer from the
full catalog of Stanford's uh artificial
intelligence offerings now we don't
offer every single course in the
Stanford catalog what we offer a lot of
them and these are some selections here
so
um you just have a lot of choice uh in
terms of what what you can choose to
study
and maybe I'll pause here and I'll say
uh Petro you you probably want to bring
this up again these two programs are
very closely related so if you were
pursuing the professional certificate
but there were a graduate class that you
wanted to take that was not part of the
professional program you could take that
graduate class you can take up to one
graduate class and have it count towards
the professional certificate as well so
that is also an option so so the full
range of grad of courses is available to
professional Learners in that regard as
well
um
it's here I'm just looking through some
of the questions and keep going
okay
I'm going to dive into just some of the
things that we already that we already
talked about uh but that are worth
emphasizing again is that the graduate
program again these are the actual
Stanford classes so you you know this
will be you'll be watching the lectures
that the on-campus students have watched
earlier in the day you'll be doing the
same assignments the same exams the same
projects that the on-campus students
will be doing and you're held to the
same standards you're graded uh in the
same way so again it's it's a it's
that's not for everyone these are highly
technical classes they're graduate level
uh classes and the School of Engineering
um you know so that they will go over
prerequisites in a second but for all of
them you you will have to be have some
level of mathematical maturity some
advanced mathematics up through uh
linear algebra and multi-variable
calculus you will need to have some
programming uh background so they're all
challenging technically demanding
classes uh that require a lot of work
the lecturers in the AI graduate program
again are the are the actual lectures
that are being delivered on campus uh
you can live stream them in some cases
There's an opportunity for two-way audio
uh you know where you can ask a question
in the actual class in most cases that's
not an option and the reason for it is
that most of our Learners are working
professionals and cannot join a class
real time uh during the day so for the
most part they're the lectures are
recorded they can be live streamed and
then they're they're posted on our
course our our course management system
learning management system where you can
watch them at any time after the fact
because they're actual classes you do
get a grade and you must earn a b or
better to keep taking classes so again
you take um you know you take one class
at a time you've got to earn a b to keep
taking classes as we said earlier and
it's it's worth repeating you earn a
Stanford transcript so you are earning
Stanford Credit you're you're you're
you're taking an actual Stanford class
you'll get a Stanford grade the same
graded and the same standard as all the
other students and if you were and one
reason why this is very appealing to a
lot of students is if you are thinking
of applying for the Master's Degree if
you do get into the master's program
you can transfer up to 18 units towards
it from that you earned while pursuing
uh the The Graduate the the uh what we
call the non-degree program taking these
individual classes so that's very
appealing and of course that could also
be true at other universities if you
apply to a master's program at another
University but whether those units will
transfer as as you know up to each
individual University
um in terms of you know I'm going to
come back to the target audience and
just and emphasize two more things uh
here so I mentioned the prerequisites
again uh worth stressing again you do
need a bachelor's degree I didn't
mention that but you're going to need
college level calculus linear algebra
probability Theory some statistics and
programming experience that's going to
be a pretty pretty accurate Baseline for
just about every single one of these
classes however you will want to also
check the individual classes for their
prerequisites so um one thing to note is
your is if you are pursuing the
certificate you're not admitted into the
certificate program the way you might be
admitted into a degree program you apply
to the program and then you're admitted
on a Class by class basis so every time
you apply or every time you enroll in a
class someone in the department is
reviewing uh your application and making
sure you meet the prerequisites for the
course now once you've successfully
completed a couple courses that becomes
less important because you've already
established that you you've established
through your successful performance that
you meeting the prerequisites for these
courses but when you first start they
will be looking at your transcript and
making sure you meet the specific
prerequisites uh for for those courses
uh
and again uh coming back to kind of
those so you know you that that the the
thing that again is worth
um as relevant here is
these are these classes have two
audience so again the schedules are
going to depend on the on the graduate
course so whereas
um whereas in the professional program
right we control the schedules we can
control the experience the the
particular manifestation or the
particular way each of these classes is
offered every year is going to change a
little bit and it will change a lot uh
depending on the instructor so a good
example here is cs221 this is the
principles of of artificial intelligence
this is the the kind of standard
introductory course that's offered at
Stanford
um and
it's taught by different faculty twice a
year it's substantially the same course
but there will be slight differences in
the way faculty deliver it and maybe
slight differences in some of the
assignments and the way they interact
with students they're just going to be
those differences it's natural in the
way these these courses are offered and
even in between courses that have the
same instructor there will be
differences in how you submit
assignments there will be differences
and the kinds of assignments that that
are that are asked of you so a lot will
depend on the faculty member who's
teaching it and that can change a lot
from year to year depend if the faculty
member changes or if the faculty member
is just updating the courses now we
update our professional courses and and
and Petro go into that but I want to
emphasize again this is not really a bug
of the graduate program this is the
feature because this is exactly what the
on-campus students are getting they're
they're they're getting the full
experience with the actual faculty and
so so are you
again same thing as I emphasizing is
that the coursework is going to depend
on The Graduate course and I want to
also come back to something that Petra
said earlier for a lot of these classes
the lectures are reported from many of
the classes not all of them but but many
of the classes the recordings are
available on YouTube through Stanford
online on just search Stanford online
YouTube and search for some of these
courses so if you want to see what these
lectures are like both in The Graduate
classes and in the professional classes
you can already do that just jump on
online additionally a lot of the syllabi
for these courses are also publicly
available online The Faculty make them
fully available so you can search a
particular course you're interested in
you can find the syllabus you can
sometimes find the lecture videos as
well and you can get a strong sense of
what the class and what the class is
like and whether it's covering the
material that's interesting to you so
we're not trying to hide what's
available here in fact we're very open
about that and I just encourage you to
search it
as we said below uh before the support
here again is is going to be faculty
office hours so there will be faculty
and teaching team office hours the
extent of those office hours is going to
again vary a lot from course to course
it's going to depend on the faculty it's
going to depend uh on their availability
uh and it's going to depend on the size
of the teaching team there are the
regular dedicated graduate teaching
assistants as there are in any Stanford
class uh and they're almost always
student forums where you can ask ongoing
questions the kind of asynchronous
manner and what faculty often do is push
those a lot of the questions into those
those channels because a lot of people
have the same questions in addition
there will usually be recorded or live
online problem sessions review sessions
discussion sections that you can or or
will be required to attend uh in order
to review material prepare for exams
review problem sets so there's a lot of
support that goes into it someone had
asked earlier and I'll repeat it again
if you are local you can attend a lot of
those offices that you can attend those
office hours hours in person you can
attend some of the exams in person as
well
so that's the core I I
um in terms of applying for the graduate
program
so there is it is still very flexible so
in terms in compared to something like
applying for a master's degree so you
will need to log on and create an
account at Stanford online uh you'll
you're going to submit your application
with transcripts and residency documents
you would submit those there's also a
statement of purpose that you include in
there and that's an opportunity for you
to explain any kind of technical
background a relevant background that's
not that doesn't show up in your
transcripts so for instance maybe you
never studied python as an undergraduate
but you've been a active python
programmer for the last six years that's
the kind of detail that would be useful
to include in your statement of purpose
it's not um you don't need to worry too
much about that it's not like uh you're
calling you know if you remember writing
uh your your college essay applications
where you have to you know write about
your life's passion it's not like that
it's it's it's General way for you to
explain why you're pursuing it and
provide any other relevant bound uh that
we should know now actually there's
there's an error here that and it's my
fault for not catching it you don't at
that point wait for the Department
decision because your application you're
not admitted into the program you're
admitted on a course by course basis so
once you've submitted your application
the next thing to do is enroll in a
course in a quarter that is offered
um and so I should mention that our
enrollment for winter quarter is open
right now it will close December 9th so
if you go to Stanford online you can see
uh classes in the AI program that are
open for enrollment right now uh for for
winter quarter you would enroll in the
course then your application will be
sent to the department they will make a
decision again it's a course by course
basis so you enroll in that first course
they're going to review your application
and say yes you can take this class you
take the class if you go to be or better
then you enroll in the next course we'll
send your application to them if they
see you've already completed of course
successfully Stanford they may just say
great they've met the prerequisites
we're not going to worry about this or
they may depending on what course you're
applying for they may look at your your
transcript again and then approve or not
approve based on that
um
Sierra I'm going to stop there this is a
little QR code you should be able this
will take you to some of the the
opportunities to enroll if you're
interested in
um
and I'm just looking through some of the
questions I'm going to stop here
um
go for it yeah my question it keeps
repeating and I think might be
interesting to people so I'm sort of an
understanding so does this mean that
this is a masters in artificial
intelligence or like how could you
compare that and like what would you
tell people if they would like to get
like the master's degree that's a great
question so this is not a masters in
artificial intelligence uh it is not
that and you are not getting admitted
into the master's program at Stanford
this is uh what is called a non-degree
program and the the so you can take
again I won't have so you can take
individual classes you can also take up
to four classes to earn an accredited
graduate certificate
so the certificate again uh if you could
think a masters at Stanford is 45 units
of coursework uh The Graduate
certificate is going to be it can depend
on on on on the courses you take but
this graduate certificate is probably
going to be between 12 and uh 16 units
so it's it's equivalent to about a third
of the coursework of a masters of a
master's degree
um it again it is an accredited
certificate so uh and and you do get the
certificate who take all four classes we
do have Learners
um
we do have Learners who just they don't
pursue a certificate they just take
individual classes and and you know so a
good example is you earn The Graduate
certificate but you want to keep taking
other courses so you can just keep
taking those courses
if you were interested in the master's
program at some point you would have to
apply through this computer science
department through Stanford for the
master's program if you were admitted
into the program then you could transfer
up to 18 units that you took as a
non-degree student
towards the master's program so some
students do try and do that they they
take they earn the certificate they get
about a third of the mass was done as a
non-degree student they apply they get
into the master's program and now
they've already got you know they've
already they're already a third of the
way through the program uh and then they
finish the rest of the master's program
maybe coming on campus and doing it in
person or continuing uh to do it
part-time or online
uh so it
what would why would you do this over a
master's program so for one it this is
much more open in terms of the
application process right the Stanford
master's degree is extremely selective
as as everyone knows it's very hard to
get into this you can just if you meet
the prerequisites and we have a seat in
the class you will be able to take the
class
um and so this is an opportunity for you
to see what it's like to take those
classes to see if this is something that
you want to do for those of you who
already have a master's degree which is
a lot of the students who do this this
is also an opportunity to say you know I
don't need it I don't need another
master's degree I have a master's degree
in computer science I've had have a
master's degree in physics or or in in
this or that I just need to fill some
gaps in my knowledge so I'm going to
take a single course or three or four
courses in order to fill in the gaps in
my knowledge around
um around artificial intelligence or
maybe particular parts of artificial
intelligence machine learning or maybe
meta learning or vision in uh you know
or robotics so you just take a few
classes in order to fill in those gaps
in your knowledge so
you know a master's degree is a big
commitment it's going to be at least two
years it's going to be for in most cases
though there are exceptions it'll be a
full-time right in-person uh uh
commitment this is a way for you to fill
in those gaps with the same rigor the
same demands but do it on a part-time
basis uh do it as an online student do
it while you're still working and again
for not master's degree isn't necessary
for everybody again as I said a lot of
our students already have master's
degrees some of them already have phds
they just don't have this particular
subject and so they want to uh flush it
out I hope that answers that question is
there anything you would add uh uh Petra
no I think you covered it well
um yeah
I'm just uh I'm looking at
um
I see some questions about signing up
for the whole program you don't you just
take one course at a time because right
you you you you you there's no
um you enroll in a course and again this
is maybe actually something else to
emphasize in a master's degree you need
to be continuously enrolled across you
know uh whatever however many quarters
it takes to earn the degree for this you
could take a class this winter say you
want to take Chris Manning cs224 and the
the you know the natural language
processing you take it this winter you
don't take anything in the spring you
don't take anything in the summer but
then you take Michael cochinder for his
decision making under uncertainty next
autumn and so great you can do that
right you don't have to be continuously
enrolled that in that way the
flexibility of the program is designed
and is as created with uh professional
Learners in mind because not everyone
has the time to stop for two or three
years to just pursue a master's degree
while still working full-time for many
people again they just need to plug a
little uh Gap in their knowledge
um though again these courts are quite
uh rigorous and they're quite technical
so I wouldn't say little maybe a a deep
hole in their knowledge they plug it
with one of these courses but they don't
need 40 they don't need nine or ten
courses they need one two three courses
and they don't want to do it all back to
back they need to spread it out because
of their work schedule their family
schedule and so this is an opportunity
to do to do that to pursue graduate
level education but with much greater
flexibility than something like a
master's degree and with less of the
commitment
it can build towards a master's degree
but this is a way to do it without uh
with all that level of commitment
um I see some questions about end of
course projects again that's gonna
that'll depend that'll depend again very
much of course by course basis um I'm
trying to think of good ones with end of
course projects a cs224u if you want to
just Google
cs224u uh or natural language
understanding with Chris Potts that's of
course with an end of course project
um and that I think that project is
specifically geared towards writing an
academic style paper um let me look at
some of the other questions here
um
and I I see questions about people who
finished College many years ago again
you can apply we do need your
transcripts it doesn't matter how long
ago you completed the college they will
consider that
um but but what you should consider is
for instance if if you took linear
algebra in 2000 and you're about to jump
into machine learning that's going to
require a lot of linear algebra
um you'll you will likely be approved
for the course if you have linear
algebra on your transcript and by the
way if you have a foreign transcript
that's not we will need a translated
copy of it if you have a transcript
that's not in English we will need a
copy of it
um
it might you know again so you've taken
you've taken a class in 2000 on linear
algebra
um now you're about to jump in machine
learning you're going to want to review
linear algebra before you jump into that
class and there are a lot of resources
that we post on our site to review those
kinds of prerequisites uh we don't offer
courses on all those prerequisites uh we
do in some cases so you might find
another Stanford class that's not part
of the artificial intelligence program
that but that provides you with some of
that foundational knowledge but what you
will want to think you submit your
application you want to think well yes
I've done linear algebra I did
multivariable calculus but I haven't
done it in 20 years probably want to
brush up on that and refresh my
knowledge
um
I'm trying to look at the uh some of the
other I I think that's pretty good we're
going to have time to answer more
questions
um uh and and I'm going to hand it off
uh to Petra and then we can come back to
some of these questions I want to make
sure we get a chance to really go over
the professional program in more detail
as well
thank you so much Pax and this was a
great uh introduction also to the AI
professional program because as we
mentioned the program is
um you know kind of built upon the
graduate uh program so a lot of the
content a lot of the product visits a
lot of the assignments are actually the
same and I will be talking more about
the differences and kind of to make sure
that you understand what a difference is
and if you are still a little bit
confused what's happening so again as
Pax mentioned this is what you will find
if you look uh look us up uh you will
find a cost so you see the exact number
over here uh and I think the main
information that many of you might be
interested in is like what classes we
actually offer and I will go a little
bit further so we currently have five uh
actually scheduled classes uh you know
ranging from artificial intelligence
principles and techniques like all the
way like the reinforcement learning you
can really pick and choose your topic we
do you also have the machine learning
class that we are currently getting
scheduled and we have a new course
getting added to the portfolio which is
cs330 deep molded task and meta learning
which I know is a course that many
people are requesting so basically this
gives you an option of taking seven uh
courses out of The Graduate portfolio as
you could see uh the selection is a
little bit uh more limited let's say but
this is intentional we always talk to
our academic director and instructors
what courses are the most relevant for
our professionals to kind of keep the
portfolio coherent so we do have this
these like seven courses you can take at
the moment uh if you would like and
Sparks mentioned and if you would like
to kind of get the professional
certificate but you can't find a course
your interest you would be interested in
you can always take one graduate course
for the purposes of the professional
program so if you're like oh I would
like to take a course on I don't know
CS2 is already deep learning because I
just saw question about that in the chat
um you can go take that class and we
will kind of get it
um get it uh accepted as part of the
professional program if you take three
courses in total
you can take the courses separately you
can also take more of them to get a
professional program it's similar as in
the graduate program right like you can
pick and choose maybe you are just
interested in something specific maybe
you would like to take the actual like
the full kind of portfolio
to give you a little bit more idea like
how it looks like like all courses are
directly based off of graduate level
equivalence so if we have access to 24n
and LP with deep learning it is based on
cs224n NLP with deep learning which is
The Graduate course we are
um talking to faculty and we try to
identify the core content by not cutting
across and making it simple but by kind
of identifying the core elements to
focus on to make it a little bit more
manageable so the whole goal of this
program is to make sure that people who
are professionals who work they don't
have time to kind of like join two
lectures maybe even like during the week
they don't have time for all the
assignments exams but they're still
interested in completing some of the
assignments and like looking up the
content and really getting the knowledge
that they have a chance to do that with
this program
we do run these as so cohorts or like
groups of people joining the course at
the same time uh we usually have around
I would say 120 people in each class uh
and you would be joining a 10-week
cohort so let's say you start your
course in January you will be taking 10
weeks to learn a material and you will
be there with like 119 potentially other
students this is actually what we find
it's actually very helpful for for many
people because you can also get in touch
with other industry professionals
because many people are actually working
Professionals in the industry so they
are already machine learning Engineers
trying to kind of get up to speed with
the material or like their data
scientists so it's like a good way also
how to get introduced to you know kind
of the industry like what's happening
out there
but as mentioned like the graduate class
is basically the same so we have the
same breathing in programming
assignments there that you will be
completing uh we do include a little bit
more uh scaffolding to try to help you
out throughout them and we try to also
identify the kind of core elements to
focus on but still those are The
Graduate level assignments uh you will
be getting support from industry
experience uh course facilitators they
all took the graduate course so they
know the material very well but I also
work in the industry uh so they can also
help you out to get an understanding how
this can be applied and yeah you can
take one course if you take three
courses you would be getting the
professional certificate
um the target audience is as I mentioned
and like what most of the people are but
it doesn't mean that like if you don't
fit into this category you don't belong
to us definitely not so most of the uh
the kind of people who take these
courses are practicing scientists and
Engineers seeking in-depth foundational
artificial intelligence Knowledge and
Skills without the need of like needing
the letter grade right so maybe you are
not even thinking of like going and
taking The Graduate uh kind of getting a
master's degree or like maybe you don't
need that letter grade maybe you're just
fine okay I want to stay up to date I
want to learn a material I would like to
take this but that's sad like we have so
such a right uh kind of population of
our Learners we have people who work in
even like I don't know social scientist
scientists like studying um and I don't
know breadth responses or anything like
that and trying to get uh get more
knowledge about this even though they
don't have any background let's say in
machine learning but they are already
good in statistics they they learn how
to code themselves and they come and
they take our courses they don't like
work with the kind of machine learning
algorithms per set every day but like
they would like to learn and kind of
um get acquainted with like all the
knowledge about it so like if you don't
finish that category you don't feel bad
I would say our program since you don't
need to also like show your master's
degree you just need to have the correct
visits if you study it on your own uh
and you have the required prerequisites
you can apply
and the prerequis is just to cover them
a little bit more detail uh many of them
apply here too so you need to know
python uh or you know like coding uh
obviously because all the programming
assignments will be done in Python uh
you should have prior knowledge of
college calculus linear algebra
probability Theory I'm mentioning here
some of the kind of more concrete
description of what this means you can
take a look at but like you don't need
to show us any of your like bachelor's
degree any like proof of that you
already work in the industry in this
area like you can like if you have this
product business you're free to free to
apply
and I will pause here a little bit on
this slide in case you would like to
give it a little bit more read
um and I'm looking at a question so I
know what to talk about after
great uh if we talk a little bit more
how the lecture videos and assignments
look like uh we included a few slides
that might give you a little bit a
better idea so the lecture videos are
directly from the classrooms or live
Zoom lectures so during pandemic uh the
classes moved online to zoom so many of
the recordings are actually on Zoom as
you see and some of the fact that this
still does that we are again moving back
to kind of in-person
classroom recordings when the instructor
is actually in front of the Blackboard
whiteboard like in front of the screen
talking
so this is just a screenshot of
percilian in cs221 like talking about
variable based models what we do in
addition to the graduate course lectures
that we segment them by topic and we
kind of edit them out to focus just on
the core elements what this means is
that if the projector broke or if there
are some like lengthy questions that
they take like 10 minutes to answer but
they might not be as relevant we cut
them out uh if uh there is a lot of
discussion that might not be as relevant
about that like if you talk about the
final projects that are not included we
cut them out to try to save you some
time with the watching of the lectures
uh we also like include lecture notes
and readings and as mentioned before
like lectures are available on YouTube
not in this segmented form but in the
full form but it's something that you
might want to take a look at to kind of
get a better idea of how this looks like
be depending on the course uh we might
have only programming assignments we
might have a combination of programming
in written we might have programming
written and quiz and in one of the
courses we actually have programming and
project but most of the time it's a
combination of written and programming
so that's why I wanted to show you how
it looks like
so you see that it actually is presented
in the original graduate level format uh
why we actually require linear algebra
and probability and all these kind of
prerequises is because faculty really uh
focuses on making sure that you
understand the content really in depth
which means that you often actually need
to like do a lot of like analysis and
proofs and derivations and all these
kind of things which would be kind of
hard to do if you don't have the prior
knowledge but what we try to do to help
you out at least a little bit is to
include some additional hints that were
originally not included because we know
where people usually get stuck on and we
try to include additional hints again we
are not trying to make it simple so it
will still be challenging this is not to
make it easy for you but like to try to
at least please help you out so you
don't get stuck on some elements that
people usually get stuck on
for the programming it's all python uh
and what I wanted to point it out is
that we built Auto graders even for
classes that might not have the auto
grader originally but most of them do
but like some of them don't we build the
auto graders uh we make sure that we
have some kind of like Ghana packages
for everybody so they have the same
environment uh and we include the auto
graders and you're able to submit your
code unlimited times up until kind of
the deadline or late deadline which
means that you are getting constantly
feedback about your code and you are
able to debug and improve
and in terms of support so we don't have
the graduate teaching assistance but we
have the course
uh we have the course facilitators who
are experienced usually industry
professionals and they took the graduate
course who will be helping you out and I
think one of the elements that is like
really working quite well in these
professional courses is the slack
Channel or slack workspace that is very
vibrant uh because as you can imagine if
you have like 120 people uh there like
this one is even like 200 uh like people
are really like asking a lot of
questions you can get responses from
course facilitators from course team
from your classmates and there's a lot
of discussion happening just on slack uh
and we also try now a little bit harder
to to make sure that people have a
chance to also like Network a little bit
more to get connected with with your
classmates who are usually like also
working professionals
uh feedback like you know we are not
here to break so everyone goes as much
detail but like people usually like our
courses I would say and I will stop here
again uh for for questions I think uh
packs they're saying is there anything I
miss that you would like to point out to
make sure you let people listen to that
part
yeah I think that was great I think
there have been a lot of great questions
that came in so maybe if I can uh tackle
a couple of them and uh so the first
thing is there was a specific question
about there are a couple questions about
the relationship between these programs
and being able to switch between them so
one really good question is is a course
taken as a professional in the
professional program would it count as a
prerequisite for one of the grad courses
we're trying to get that in place with
the uh with this CS Department that's
not in place right now so if there were
for instance a graduate class that
required you to take cs229 or it's
equivalent uh we don't have official
approval that those would count and
we're working on getting that official
we're working on getting that official
approval but in general there's no
nothing to stop you from switching
between these programs again I want to
emphasize that unlike a master's degree
where you're admitted into the program
or an undergraduate degree or a PhD
program where you're admitted into the
program and you're there until you
complete it or you drop out
these are are really more you you're
expressing interest in pursuing a group
of courses but you can just take a
single course you can take more courses
than than that are required for the
certificates
um you can jump between the two programs
uh so if you wanted to take cs229 as a
professional uh course and then take
um you know cs231n uh yeah I'm sorry I'm
giving you all these numbers because I
know the numbers better than I know the
names you want to take machine learning
as a as a professional and then you
wanted to take computer vision uh on on
The Graduate side that's totally fine
you can jump between these programs
um you can take more classes or fewer
classes than are required for the
certificates again these are you should
consider these more on a course by
course basis and the programs are more
or less giving you a pathway or a way to
stack some of those courses together to
earn a larger credential
um so there's a lot of uh uh back back
and forth there that that's possible
um and then I I wanted to also mention
on The Graduate well I'll pause there uh
Petra do you see some other questions
around that or related that you wanted
to address
um I I think they were
some questions about specific classes
yeah those you should be able to find so
I saw a specific thing about machine
learning with graphs that's not taught
by andrewing that's taught by Yuri
leskovic uh I hope I'm pronouncing his
last name correctly he's uh he teaches
in both the programs that's machine
learning with graphs uh yeah Andrew ing
teaches cs229 which is machine learning
and he usually only teaches it in the
Autumn and the graduate program the
current professional version of the
course is based off of Andrew ing's
lectures
um but again we there are a variety of
Faculty are teaching these classes
um and and yeah some very different
programs I I guess one other thing that
comes up in terms of that that is being
asked is is I'm interested in the
graduate program I haven't taken some of
this stuff in 30 years
you can absolutely do one of the
professional classes to start with right
um and then if that's working well for
you and it allows you the time to sort
of
um to to so let me back up a good
example would be machine learning very
demanding class both in the professional
and in The Graduate and graduate side of
things and it does require a lot of math
it requires a lot of you know strong
programming background for the grad
course
um you're going to have a lot you're
going to have you know again 15 to 20
percent more time per week or you're
gonna have to spend on the assignments
that are are in the class itself so if
you're a little bit Rusty it might be
great to do that as the professional
program use that extra time you're
saving to really invest in reviewing the
prerequisites you're not although you
are graded paths no pass in the
professional program correct I think is
it past no pass uh Petra I think that's
why we designate it
um there's less anxiety around a grade
right so again you know these are
personal preferences in the professional
program it you're not being given a
grade it's uh you know the the 20 uh
some as we you know mentioned we're
focusing on the 80 that is the core
content the other 20 is optional and a
lot of people choose to do it but you
don't have the pressure where you have
to do it and so that allows a slightly
less you know it's it's not any less
rigorous in terms of the content but it
makes fewer demands on you and that can
allow you to sort of build in the time
to sort of um you know to to polish that
Rusty math and to sort of build up on
the prerequisites and get back into the
learning mode and then if you are
interested you could jump into the
graduate program having proven yourself
in the professional program so it could
be a good way if you haven't done this
or haven't been back to school in a
while that could be a really good way uh
to get a feel for for what it's like
um I saw a couple of questions maybe
even more
um questions about people who live
abroad and you know if it is an issue if
you live in Europe or southeast Asia or
like wherever you are I would say for
the air professional program uh even the
majority of the people is outside of the
US like you won't be alone uh I am
guessing and parks would know more that
also many people to take the AI graduate
program are abroad so again like you
won't be alone uh and uh since
everything is pre-recorded and all the
calls are scheduled ahead of the time if
you can't make it you can watch the
recording or again like we try to make
sure that we uh schedule the times in a
way that are accessible for people or
around the globe but obviously we can't
cover all the time zones so what we
usually do since we have the largest
audiences within kind of U.S Canada
South America time zone and Europe ish
time zone we try to schedule calls that
would cover all of that and then
um you know like you can watch the
recording sometimes you're even able to
join from Japan or from China or
wherever you are uh but like we have I
don't think we have ever had much much
issue with people from abroad that it
would not be able to follow up with the
material since in the AI professional
program you also have access to the
slack Channel and your course
facilitator you're able to ask them
questions and schedule calls in times
that work better for you so
um I would say you won't be alone if
you're abroad and like we try to make
sure that we adjust it a little bit
packs I don't I don't know if you have
anything to add about that
uh no as you said there are there are
plenty of of students who who are are
taking the AI graduate programs as well
from from uh other places
um again the as I mentioned earlier you
know with the professional program we
have the sort of luxury of Designing it
specifically for a remote audience for
The Graduate Again The Faculty are you
know and the majority of the students
are Pacific time they're insta you know
they're in the Bay Area they're they're
in Stanford right they're at Stanford
and they're taking the course
um so it can be a little bit of a
challenge uh for for remote Learners who
are in in really different time zones
it's it it's um
you know the faculty who often and the
teaching teams will make adjustments to
help accommodate that but if they have
you know it can be hard to accommodate
every time zone so it may mean that you
you know the only office hours that are
available to you are like 10 o'clock
your time
um you know 10 o'clock P.M your time or
something like that so there can be
challenges there
um but for many students that's worth it
they they want the actual you know they
want they want the uh the The Full
Experience
um
I did I saw a question about tuition
reimbursement I just want to mention
that that's a question for your company
uh and it's not we we don't know that
would be I'd ask your your organization
many I know for both programs many
students are being uh reimbursed by
their organizations for taking the
classes uh but the the extent of that
will depend
um and in terms of prerequisites getting
a lot of questions for prerequisites so
I would go to if I think we link to with
those QR codes and they should be links
in the uh in the user interface there
and you're kind of
um uh portal is there should be links to
the the actual program pages and we link
out and mention some prerequisites there
you can find it in the program planning
document for the AI graduate program and
I think there are actual um maybe a link
as well in the professional program to
to some resources for brushing up on on
your prerequisites in terms of the
graduate program there are other
graduate classes that are not in the AI
program that would cover some of these
prerequisites mostly in the programming
side of things so if you don't have a
strong background in computer science
and you need to brush up on that we
offer an extensive selection of
Stanford's uh computer science classes
are open to professional Learners
um
I saw also questions about passing and
how difficult it is to pass so I can
answer that from the AI professional
program portfolio there was even a note
like if people even like failed at and I
must say they do but it depends how much
effort they put into the work so I would
say if we start with like 100 percent uh
we do have a drop transfer deadline that
lasts three weeks into the course and we
see that maybe
10 15 of the people who started my job
drop off uh either like transfer to the
next kind of cohort because they have
some other commitments coming up work is
busy family life is busy whatever is
happening already drop the course
completely because it's not something
they were looking uh looking uh to kind
of get which is totally fine if we
understand that and that's why we have
this option out of the people stayed in
the course again I would say 15 10 to 15
period that 10 to 15 percent of the
people don't make it uh don't make it
and they don't pass what do we see if
you put the effort and if you do have
the prerequisites since there is the
flexibility of kind of passing 70 of the
assignments you should be able to make
it uh but it said like we can't promise
that for everybody it really depends
again like you have the prerequisites
are you able to keep up people who
usually don't have that they find out in
the first three weeks and those are the
people who drop uh but if you stay in
the course and put the afford your you
like again like I can't promise it like
I can't promise you that you will pass
but like you are more likely to pass
that than not but on the other hand it
doesn't mean that if you enroll like you
will pass for sure we know there are so
many certifications out there that if
you just show up like people will give
you certificate this is not us
definitely
and that's the same for the graduate
program obviously uh we have quite a few
people will join and then drop with I
think the the drop deadlines usually the
first two weeks of the quarter
um and you you join and and you get a by
the way if you drop in the first two
weeks of the quarter you get a full
refund minus a hundred dollar processing
fee
um and so that's when most people that's
when kind of the reality hits them um if
you've never taken one of our courses or
you've been out of school for a while uh
you can forget how fast-paced and how
hard a quarter uh AI you know how hard
at graduate level class is and it may
not be that it's too hard for you it may
just be that you've suddenly been
assigned a major project at work and and
then you have to drop it once you pass
that drop deadline uh you you you do you
can't um drop the class without it being
reflected on your transcript because
just like a normal that Stanford student
Cannot drop a class after the drop
deadline and not have it show up in some
way on their transcript so there are
still opportunities to withdraw a
request an incomplete uh throughout the
quarter on that and incomplete for
instance is if something came up at the
end of the course and you'd completed
most of the work already but say you
couldn't take the final exam or couldn't
complete the final project because
something came up you could request an
incomplete and complete it at a later
time
um so uh you know again as Petra said
there are students who you know just as
there were students who fail these
classes or don't do well in these
classes
um but they're but you know a lot of the
students I'd say most of the the
non-degree students who are pursuing
these as professionals and who stick
with it do that first two weeks and say
yeah I can do this uh they you know they
make it through the class and they
they'll come back and take more classes
um
so you know again it's it's a challenge
and for both of these it's a it's a
serious commitment of time and energy
um you know as Petra said that you you
can't just show up these are these are
they're hard classes and that's really
on you know maybe one of the secrets
about learning hard things is it's a
hard work to do that and that's true
here as well and in fact they I think we
always I'm always impressed by anyone
who has the time to do this these are
these are quite these are hard very hard
classes
um
I'm seeing questions about sequencing
um
this is about uh it's a 10 of it don't
pass me they don't it's
so that the the question about the
passing uh that that's related to the
professional program and not the
graduate program so the professional
program doesn't issue B's uh so that
would be they're not passing the class
um
I I think that addresses we're at time
and I think I know we haven't addressed
every question that came in
um but I I think at this point we really
appreciate you all joining and asking
the questions we'll probably be holding
more sessions part of having the session
itself was was a opportunity for us to
learn from all of you to see the
questions that were coming in and for us
to prepare more materials to answer
those questions on our website and to
hold future sessions like this so we can
better address these questions I do want
to remind everyone that if you are
interested in Rolling after this
graduate courses are open for winter
quarter are open for enrollment now you
can go to Stanford online and there are
some professional courses as well that
are also open for enrollment
um thank you again for your time we
really appreciate your questions we
appreciate your participation for those
who've already taken courses thank you
uh for doing that and those of you who
will be uh good luck and we look forward
to seeing you in those classes
yeah thank you also from my end thank
you so much for joining trying to type
in more more responses as we go thank
you bye